remember the definition of an
agent of influence a person in position
of authority or power who can influence
influence public opinion or policy
in russia's favor is there any question
in your mind
that donald trump has done that he has
kissed putin's ring
he is cow towed to him he has
when russians put bounties on american
soldiers in afghanistan
and those soldiers die trump does
nothing about it
he refuses to push back on putin
and as i said the people i talked to for
this book
on the record and the people i've talked
to for a podcast i've done based on this
book called whirlwind
on the record former heads of the cia
former chiefs of
russian operations at the cia former fbi
counterintelligence agents
trump's own national security adviser
h.r mcmaster
they say that trump is aiding and
abetting putin
why why okay is the great mystery of our
time
yes why does he do it why does he bend
his knee to boot
i raise the question of why and i have
several theories about it
i'd love to hear it a few days ago my
old newspaper the new york times
published details from trump's tax
returns
you read that story i did all of it
trump owes percy's personally on the
hook
okay hundreds of millions of dollars
the grand total is 421 million he is on
the hook for about three quarters of
that personally
not the trump organization to whom does
he owe that money
and who will help him pay it back now
you know about security clearances right
you're ex-military i do you know
something about the work how the world
works
there's levels to it what is the number
one red flag for somebody
who's getting a security clearance
financial challenges financial
difficulties
okay and the reason for it is motivation
meaning you will be desperate to make a
deal that may be
worse than that look the russian
intelligence services are very good at
penetrating financial institutions
okay they have a very close and very
illicit
set of relationships with deutsche bank
the german bank that loaned hundreds of
millions of dollars to donald trump
after his sixth bankruptcy when no one
else would touch him
okay they know
who donald trump holds that money to and
they can hold this over
his head compromising information
compromised
as they would put it so that's one
theory of the case
there is another theory of the case a
little less scary
perhaps an agent of influence what does
he do
he's not stealing secrets
he's using his influence to affect
public opinion
and public policy by the way this is not
my definition
this is the definition in the american
counter-intelligence handbook
putin has flattered him putin has given
him political support
openly and covertly given trump's
vanity his ego maybe all
putin has to do is influence him
and win influence in return that is
personally my theory of the case
because i don't have knowledge of who
trump owes that money to
but he doesn't know it to the federal
credit union i'll tell you that
so we got two of them so far so the
first one is the theory is finance out
of the 400 million dollars give or take
421.
three quarters is his own debt deutsche
bank who's going to help him out here is
there a
finance possibly linked to russia no one
knows second one is putin flat at him
he's giving him love back so maybe
that's the way that that's taking place
is there any other ones that you have
donald trump first went to moscow in
1987.
he had a check wife to whom he was
unfaithful and a pronounced taste for
slavic women
none of that matters he was trying to
build a luxury hotel
in partnership with the soviet
government
across red square from the kremlin if
the kgb
didn't put his target a target on his
back
at that moment we got a bridge here in
brooklyn that connects with manhattan
would you like to buy it
it would have been criminally negligent
of the kgb not to target donald trump
at that point and we won't know the
answer to the question of
why trump behaves this way until the cia
recruits
the guy in the russian intelligence
service who
has seen a thick file that says d trump
on the cover but i guarantee you that
file exists
and that file has existed since 1987.
okay so so that's a that's a different
angle he went there in 87 so wanted to
build a hotel
in partnership with soviet government
it's uh
behooves the kgb model of a regime to
hold them accountable without getting
anything in return i can see that part
okay
is there any other ones that you have
outside of those three
okay so that hotel
that luxury hotel in moscow trump was
still trying to build it
in 2015 and 2016 when he was running for
president he was going to make a lot of
money
off that hotel he was looking at 300
million dollars
which is about the sum of money
that he's personally liable for on debts
that are coming due
to three years from now his uh business
associate
in this a convicted felon named felix
sater
who happened to be in partnership
business partnership
with the trump organization dangled
a 50 million dollar penthouse at the top
of this hotel
in front of poo throw it in deal
sweetener
donald trump said at the time when he
was running for president that he had no
business interest in russia but he did
a major business interest that
if it had gone through and he didn't
become president
which looked like a pretty good bet four
years ago right
it would heal him financially this deal
and he was asked about it do you have
any business interests in russia he was
asked about on the campaign
trail and he said no i have no business
interests in russia
why is he lying i don't have an answer
to that
is it because he lies for sport because
he likes to engage in what he calls
truthful hyperbole or did he have
something to hide
these are questions that i explore in
the last chapters of this book
and they need to be answered now you'll
recall
that in the spring of 2017
donald trump fired the fbi director jim
comey
and he said on tv with lester holt on
nbc news
that he'd fired him because the fbi was
investigating
the connections between team trump and
team putin
in the 2016 campaign this set off a
rather large red flag
at fbi headquarters the bureau the fbi
had just been decapitated
why trump told them why it was because
of the russia investigation
so at that time it took about 12 days
the time between
comey's firing and the appointment of
robert mueller's the special counsel
with a very limited brief to look into
connections between team trump and team
putin
mueller never looked at his financials
at fbi headquarters
the senior counterintelligent agent
who's going to run this case
said it was like those 12 days were like
the cuban missile crisis
the difference was that the cuban
missile crisis lasted 13 days
and i had a happy ending because
the fbi set out can you imagine how hard
this was
to mount a counter-intelligence
investigation
of the president of the united states to
determine
the answer to the questions i just
raised
why why did he behave this way with
putin why did he fire the fbi director
to kill the russia investigation
that investigation never happened it was
strangled in its crib
at the highest levels of the trump
justice department
and that is why we do not know the
answer to these questions
that investigation never happened it
vanished into thin air